so marjorie taylor greene tweeted that  there's an energy crisis because of a  force shift to so-called green energy  this is completely and totally absurd  the energy crisis to the extent that it  exists is happening because of drought  it's happening because of record high  temperatures forcing people to have to  use air conditioning it's happening in  texas because texas has decided to  isolate their power grid from every  neighboring state the only state to do  this in the contiguous 48 states don't  believe marjorie taylor green as if any  of you would be so dumb as to do that i  know my followers aren't dumb enough to  follow marjorie